je
[Musique]
je m'appelle kdn je suis écrit henin je
préfère écrivant je n'aime pas écrivaine
que ça fait j'écris en vain mais en fait
moi je me définit d'abord comme un
individu peut-être féminin mais
individus dès l'instant où ce qui te
fait de moi une femme reste des
accessoires ce sont des attributs
donc il faut que je me dis que je suis
une femme mais pour moi ces attributs
sont juste des accessoires dont je me
sers pour on va dire me décorer quand
j'ai envie de séduire par exemple très
peu de femmes ont de grands prix comme
le prix nobel de la littérature comme le
goncourt mais je pense qu'il n'est pas
il n'est pas très aisé pour moi de dire
que c'est parce que ce sont des femmes
moi je me dis que quand on se considère
déjà comme une femme et qu'on se dit que
c'est parce qu'on est une femme pauline
arrive pas on se ferme les portes déjà
soi même peut-être que je me trompe mais
moi ça m'arrange de le penser comme ça
comme ça ça m'évite de mettre des
barrières de me dire que je suis une
femme
donc je n'y arriverai pas
[Musique]
avec mon premier roman donc sous le
regard des étoiles j'avais écrit parce
que j'avais besoin de hurler c'était
elle crie que je poussais en écrivant ce
livre parce qu'il m'a été inspiré d'une
histoire que j'ai vécu c'est une
histoire vraie donc c'est un racisme que
j'ai vécu en france qui a provoqué à moi
une sorte de désamour pour la france je
me souviens que j'étais tellement en
colère que j'avais besoin de de sortir
ce que j'avais dans mes tripes et la
seule manière que vous avez trouvé à
l'époque de le faire c'est d'écrire
quand la personne s'est adressé à moi
elle s'est adressée à une femme et noire
donc ça me faisait donc deux maladies on
va dire de pathologies quoi et qu'il lui
plaisait pas et aujourd'hui j'aime dire
que je suis franco sénégalaise tout
simplement parce que les plus vécu en
france qu'au sénégal
on se rend pas compte que la langue
française n'est pas française la langue
française et francophone
c'est à dire qu'elle appartient à tous
ceux qui la parlent ce quand j'étais à
dakar la langue française était une
évidence pour moi j'écris en français ça
c'est naturel c'est même pas la france
qui fait que j'écris en français c'est
que je ne sais écrit qu'en français
[Musique]